de nos excuses les coûts des régions
sont pas ce qu'on attendait 5 millions
d'abonnés c'est tout simplement un
chiffre incroyable donc 5 million de
mercis je voulais faire un truc un petit
peu différent des jeux vidéo de ce qu'on
fait d'habitude pour fêter ça mais je me
suis dit quoi de mieux que de faire un
jeu d'horreur dans la vraie vie on est
lâché dans un lieu totalement hanté du
cul et le but c'est juste trouver la
sortie sachant que je n'y vois
absolument rien ça vous dire c'est parti
on entre dans le lieu hanté du cul ok on
est dans le lieu à lens rien vous ne
touchez pas les manceaux ne touchez pas
aux décors prenez votre temps ne courait
pas assez dangereux voudrais pas que
à l'intérieur les garder le silence
fraude il veille à ce que la soirée se
passait n'essayez pas de réveiller leur
fallait trouver la sortie
d'accord on est tombé dedans
ok légende est en train de rentrer dans
le dans le manoir
je suis je suis tout sauf rassurer j'ai
un petit stick qui est censé éclairer un
peu
nlyte sur mon visage ok il ya des
marches
la démarche c'est que là
mais je pense
je te l'ont pas attendu la teneur
souvent
mais gaston plus bordel
tu
debian ok ok ok ok
rit sous cape may c'est un jeu de rôles
ainsi que les clés où sont les clés ces
fonds sont offerts
on attend jusqu'à vendredi mais mon
choix je suis revenu au même endroit au
quai mavia nul maintenant je suis revenu
au même endroit assez pourri ça je suis
nulle [ __ ] ok j'ai juste par michel
hockey occupe et s'est occupée vous
pouvez pas quoi ok
et la critique y aller de l'avant mais
je pense que c'est faux est ce que tu me
trahis famille d'une petite fille attend
c'est sur ces photos on sait jamais où
nous on est des gagnants des gens bien
on veut les sauver
oui tant attendu mais la caméra duo il
ya mais a priori on va pas être trop des
dieux je n'en avais pas je n'en ai pas
je tendais pas je n'en ai pas
j'entendais pas d'accord je peux aller
nulle part en fait il ya des gens qui
parlent je m'entendais de cris ok ok je
veux juste passer juste passer d'o'shea
saisi bassil vous retirer ses katas
jusqu'au bout pourquoi ne pas y voit
beaucoup doit boire un café que cet
homme est en poche de passer
plus tard diaz au grand âge s'accroît du
parminou est ce qu elles sont un peu la
barre à papa de crime hong a coûté 4
alors arrête de jouer au dessus j'ai
compris j'allais me sentais super bon
c'est coco chanel ça ça c'est coco
chanel inconnu faut on me semblait pas
plus tard il faut
juste passé je viens en paix pour passer
devinez pourquoi
ok une devinette j'écoute la devinette
je peux t'offrir la porte tu peux me
faire la fortune la jeunesse éternelle
oui ok
je vis des dates blue très joli cette
jolie qu'ils se font tuer tuer tuer je
sais pas je sais pas le cas ok
[ __ ] ça qui est devant j'étais abonnée
machine au bois le monstre ok mais pour
lui ça veut dire non toi ok attaque il a
doublé
foppa planète rouge qui chante une
berceuse que je fasse quoi une berceuse
j'y vais arriver au corps comme un
toboggan
ouais mais bon comme ça j'ai fait
quelques frayeurs brocas un bordel au
hockey ça va ça va ça va comment tu
t'appelles
c'est un excellent nom je veux juste
passer genre
laisse-moi passé oui donc j'attends
j'attends dans l'ohio
je suis patient j'adore noir tu veux
goûter un roland goetz 13 non jaro tait
sale ça suffit
je me mets ma tata et à sa maison ok
alors je fais pas je fais pas jouer avec
toi tout de suite ok c'est un mur je
m'en vais
à tort
je boucle à ok bientôt
john deere
heureusement pas pourquoi je suis parti
sans mentir
parfois je sens mon coeur
qui sort du
petite pause aux socialistes
un an
veillant au prs totalement là
surtout est allé voir de quoi on raté
ok
l'arrivée
une première manifestation
jarrett
vous
j'y vais merci merci aux gars
puis ben là mais c'est quoi ce bordel
mais [ __ ] j'ai touché des poils
partout on dit tu le mur et faire des
papouilles jambes
c'est horrible je vivais plus tard tu la
trappe super-frelon la sema show
je m'écrase un mois le mouvement excuse
moi je demandai je vais juste pas là
excuse moi le moose excuse moi je m'en
vais juste je m'en vais je vais aller en
paix là bas mais à toi mon travail chez
un proche pour l'alliance j'aime bien
jouer avec ma vie où je suis je suis je
suis une salade je suis une fougère je
ne suis pas de la viande
mais bonjour ok ok ok salue les toiles
je suis une salade
situé carnivores c'est je suis pas le
beau mike attaque est ok attends je
regrette un peu l acia mines ma vache
ils blaguent passé mon je vous le dis ok
c'est un abonné c'est un abri même fait
un peu peur alors tu cela que mes vidéos
si tu veux me désabonne toi vraiment
d'idée des commentaires méchants sur moi
sur les forums mais là ce sont vos
doigts croches yeux laisse moi ok ok tu
peux pas
à quel genre à cacher
türk hgh et donc vous allez bon voilà
roth ya un bruit trop sono ça sent pas
bon
la paire la plus totale sa soirée sans
mon gars
après ok avec un trousseau de jeu mais
ça ressemble avant l'essor plus tard
à
ah c'est bon
ok c'est la sortie on a réussi à garder
tous ensemble je sais beau parent je sus
je suis tellement
et j'en suis fière de cette vidéo espace
nous a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
aller mais comme d'habitude c'était
intense riche en émotions j'ai transpiré
comme un porc [ __ ] l'est moins c'est
que des terrifiants et jouer leur rôle à
merveille
enfin je veux pas leur olemps t'aider
c'était de vrais monstres 1 encore merci
voilà c'est pour moi j'aime bien dire
des petits merci comme ça futile à des
taux aussi nombreux à suivre les vidéos
il pu écouter gta ça va vous plaire
encore longtemps et qu'on aura
l'occasion de faire d'autres trucs un
peu spéciaux comme cette petite vidéo
annonce l'entrée dans une prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien et a très vite
chaumont pis
et